the police officer charged in a deadly
dui here in the valley has been allowed
to return to connecticut while the case
goes through court robert ferraro is
accused of killing his passenger a
fellow officer while driving drunk
hector mejia has the latest from court
[Music]
house arrest was removed as one of the
conditions for ferraro's release and his
attorney said it was negotiated with
prosecutors and without an objection in
court the judge allowed it with
additional conditions
robert ferraro is out on bond bail had
been sent at a hundred thousand dollars
i'm going to impose some additional
conditions those conditions include no
driving plus alcohol monitoring weekly
phone call check-ins and turning in his
passport ferraro hired high-profile
attorney gabriel grosso this case is a
horrible tragedy regardless of what what
ends up happening in this case
regardless of that it's a huge loss for
everyone ferraro was formally charged
thursday morning two felonies dui
resulting in death and reckless driving
the new haven patrol officer was
visiting las vegas with three other
officers when metro police say ferraro
was driving under the influence and lost
control of a rented rolls royce near
decatur and spring mountain last friday
the car rolled killing 35 year old
officer joshua castellano
was high school buddies with
mr ferraro they've known each other for
years they went through the police
academy together the police department
placed ferraro on administrative leave
badge gun
bullet proof vest
all that police equipment had to be
turned in and according to the defense
attorney ferrara already has a flight
book for tomorrow morning out for
connecticut the next court hearing is
set for october 7. reporting in downtown
hector mejia live local now